If you built this rocket launcher from a previous
project, then you're going to need some rockets.
In this video, you'll learn how to make these
durable, high pressure rockets, for about
5 cents each.
It's a beautiful day, so I'm taking this project
outside on my patio. I'll get started by placing
my rocket launcher with the barrel overhanging
this ledge. I'm going to start making this
fairly quickly, so I'll plug in a hot glue
gun to get it warming, and start cutting this
piece of paper right down the center. One
half will act as a spacer and the other half
will form rocket body. Let's roll the first
half tight around the barrel and tape it to
itself, then take the other piece and wrap
it the same way. Now we have 2 layers to this
roll, and we'll need to position them so that
the top layer is overhanging just enough to
press the sides inward from 4 directions.
All the paper on the tip is overlapping so
it's time to add some electrical tape. Start
at the base of the top layer, and wind it
in a circular fashion until it's wrapped all
the way up the body. This tape is very durable
and perfect for holding these rocket bodies
together under pressure. When we get to the
tip, let's wrap several layers of tape over
the top and around the sides because this
is the part that's going to take the most
abuse. When that's rounded and smoothed out,
we can wrap one more layer down the rocket
body, ending right back where we started.
This rocket will need some fins, so I've ripped
a piece of cardboard off a box, and when I've
squared up the edges a bit, I'll make a mark
a third of the way up the body, and another
mark as wide as the barrel. Using a straight
edge, we can connect the dots, and cut the
fin out. Now we have a template to make more
fins, and we'll need 4, so let's trace those
out and begin cutting. This way we've managed
to keep the fins all about the same size.
They're not perfect, but hey, it's not like
this is real rocket science. Ok, hot glue
goes on this end, and then presses into place
flush with the base of the electrical tape.
When it's hardened, rotate the fin down, and
place another one on top. I'm trying to make
all the fins relatively symmetrical, and this
seems like a good way to get the job done.
Ok, we're done with the hot glue, so we can
unplug that, and this rocket is nearly finished.
I'm adding 2 wraps of tape just over the tips,
and when I smooth it all out, it's finished.
There's just one thing left to do, and that's
remove the inner layer of tubing. This will
create a slight gap making it easier to load
the rocket. I'm also adding extra tape to
the bottoms of the fins to ensure this little
rocket is super durable. I think it's ready
to test out. I'll use my air compressor to
charge the system to 135 PSI, and once we've
closed the ball valve we can disconnect the
air hose, and now we're completely portable.
Ok, I've got my rocket set, and the neighborhood
is clear. Winds are calm, so it's time to
fire. That's a good shot, and landed all the
way down at the end of the street. This is
an insane amount of pressure for a paper rocket
to withstand, and would blow most little rockets
to bits! But this design seems to get the
results, because even with all the pressure,
they shoot amazingly straight. And they can
be used again and again! I still can't get
over the distance these cheap little things
can cover. This one just went 300ft and flew
over my house. I'm really happy with how this
project worked out, and at a cost of about
5¢ each I feel like I've got my money's worth.
That's it for now. If you liked this project,
perhaps you'll like some of my others. Check
them out at www.thekingofrandom.com